Ciao ragazzi son finite le feste e credo
che sia arrivato il momento di mangiare
in maniera sana, di mangiare in maniera
equilibrata e di spurgare tutto quello
che abbiamo ingerito dal... Da ferragosto? Da quant'è che si magna? Io da 24 anni che magno
Queste vacanze sono state abbastanza
toste per tutti quanti noi
io ho preso credo 4 kg tu quanto hai preso? Sette.
Sei esploso, il Big Bang è avvenuto dopo un
pranzo di Natale. Tu in questo momento sei la rappresentazione di un miracolo della vita cioè nel senso che la tua vita
E per reiniziare quest'anno ho
pensato di buttarmi a cucinare col
microonde in modo da creare qualcosa di
veloce e non ho trovato qualcosa di
leggero quindi faremo delle patatine
fritte e scopriremo anche come fare la maionese e il
ketchup in pochissimo tempo.
Partiamo subito con il procedimento
possa avere un "Sì Chef?" Sì Chef...
in contemporanea... Sì Chef! Perfetto! Le voci
che sentirete sono quelle dei miei
familiari abbiamo Chef Rico, Chef Mario e
Chef Ottavio, grazie Chef Ottavio per
essere venuta qui con noi. Abbiamo
bisogno di una patata, dell'olio, del sale,
basta... Questo fa capire quanto sia facile
insomma. Per prima cosa prendiamo la
patata e sciacquiamola
Non si può sciacquare con sapone e borotalco? Col sapone liquido non si sciacquano gli alimenti. Sì Chef! No?
Facciamo questo, facciamo questo,
facciamo questo, facciamo questo, si...
Prendiamo un piatto e una mandolina
che serve per affettare sottile, sottile
le cose e perdere le dita perché non ha
un proteggi dita questa vero? Io mi son fatta malissima con quella. Ti sei fatta male? Sì
Ottavio nove dita. Ottavio otto dita...
Fanno un rumore strano...
direi invitante. Allora dobbiamo scusa, no ho sbagliato. Ricette cancerogene
Prendiamo le chips, parolone le chips mettiamole in un sì va beh potevate farlo
prima capito? Ho preso questo ma ho
sbagliato con un pochino di olio di semi
perché non trovate quello lì d'oliva
mettiamo e poi comunque è molto
meglio farle a casa
ok il microonde è una scommessa con la
vita delle persone. C'è Gualtiero Marchesi che bestemmia
A questo punto arriva il difficile, prendete il piatto di vetro del microonde
Quella roba che nessuno lava mai. Prendete della
carta da forno e iniziate a ritagliare un cerchio che
sia perfettamente dentro le forbici da
cucina di Pierfra so queste qui
dell'Albero Azzurro?
Prendiamo quindi adesso le nostre chips
e le disponiamo in uno strato. Ma allora
sa quello che fa. Ne voglio una bella proprio
che tu dici "Ah questa è quella che mi mangio
e mi da felicità" Ma nessuna di queste
mi sta dando gioia. Ma dacci una probabilità di successo
Successo... bassa, molto bassa. Cinque minuti al microonde, come funziona? male ma date si aspetta patate stream
Patate! Patate, sì patate. Ah aspetta patate sting, bake gratin. French fries B-4. B-4 oh, oh!
Mi dice 4 minuti. Ma sono delle ombre. Fa vedere? Chef Ottavio ti fa male, ti fanno male queste onde
Oh regà veramente si stanno dorando! Beh si stanno un po' carbonizzando in realtà eh
Sale. Ah dovevo mettercelo... Ora!
Facciamo un altro esperimento prima
di assaggiarle, mi ero dimenticato pure
di metterci il sale quindi a questa botta
li mettiamo un po' di sale. Pensavo fosse una scelta proprio
dello chef che il sale fa male. Sì è vero ehm, sì ehm,
è vero, Il fatto è che sono molto sottili
queste, molto sottili, quindi vengono
delle carezze. Queste non sono cips, queste
sono carezze di patata. Che può sembrare anche il titolo di un porno. A questo punto po di
sale. No Gu scusa ma il sale
non si mette così. Ma mi si bloccano i peletti dentro
Riproviamoci, tre minuti. Allora ripartiamo subito adesso con le
salse facciamo la prima che teoricamente
dovrebbe essere più fati... Fatima.
Guardate che belle...
Mettiamo un secondo le patatine da parte, per la maionese abbiamo bisogno di un
minipimer, un uovo, olio di semi, aceto, io ho preso quello di mele perché non trovo
l'aceto quello bianco, quindi potrebbe essere una m***a vabbè
Sale, le dosi non le so quindi credo che
andrò a occhio. Spostiamoci da quest'altro lato. Prendiamo l'uovo...
Non ci credo! Ma è un miracolo! Ha preso gli ingredienti col c**o
Un pizzico di sale, un pochino d'aceto. Dovremmo andare a filo con l'olio
Gu quanto olio stai mettendo?
Eccola qua
MaioNOse. Allora l'aspetto ce l'ha della maionese. Ok a noi quello interessa, puoi dire che è maionese. Ok!
Chef Mario vuoi venire?
Una patatina... Perfetto, grazie. Immergila
in questo ben di Dio. Beh ma l'aspetto non è male eh.
Al primo impatto può sembrare... Poi arriva tipo il diavolo
Passiamo al ketchup. Per fare questo ketchup tipo in due minuti a casa serviranno del concentrato di
pomodoro, dello sciroppo d'acero, torna l'aceto di mele, polvere di cipolla, origano e la maionese
Partiamo subito col procedimento che in
realtà è molto semplice, prendete un
bicchiere e una forchetta. Ma che ce lo
dobbiamo mangiare questo? È un po'
concentrato tanto... Mettiamo il concentrato di pomodoro, le dosi non le so, non ne ho idea
Un pochino di sciroppo d'acero, basta ho
esagerato
già lo so. Aceto di mele... Ma scusa nel
ketchup c'è la cipolla? Ma perché c'è lo sciroppo d'acero? Questo è un ketchup
sperimentale e veloce...
No, non c'è, non c'è. No, no, no, non c'è e
origano... Volevo fare qualcosa di veloce
per le persone che ci seguono da casa, sale...
E mo mischi ed esce il ketchup?
Manca dello sciroppo d'acero
di sicuro. Fermi regà... Stai creando?
Non capisco perché c'è un barile di...
Scusate... Scuse accettate
Intanto preparo
Siamo arrivati alla fine di questa ricetta, queste qui erano le mie
patatine fritte in quattro minuti con
ketchup in due minuti e maionese in un
minuto praticamente uno snack in meno di una p***a
Fatemi sapere con delle foto, con delle
stories, taggatemi su Instagram, dove vi
pare, se proverete questa ricetta e
soprattutto fatemi sapere come vi è
venuta. Io naturalmente vi do un appuntamento alla prossima domenica con un'altra puntata di...
Sentire ma volete provare un secondo? Io se non ti offendi la maionese...
Anzi riproverò pure la maionese... Questa è la patatina di cui parlavi. Prova prima la
maionese, è bella da vedere eh infaatti per questo mi fai arrabbiare. Poi c'ha quel
sapore di asfalto. È terribile... Regà... Che cos'è? È terribile... Prendi quella che stavi
prendendo che serve una bella tosta.
Questa cioè... Vai!
Magari di aspetto è meno bella della
maionese... Vai!
Madonna... Questa veramente...
È disgustosa...
Questa ha del ketchup  in sé,
questa ha del ketchup. Cacchio! Eh te l'ho detto
che ci sono un po' rimasto strano
anch'io.Cioè tu hai messo soltanto sta roba dentro...
È vero, solo quello hai usato. C'ho messo il resto ma poi ci ho caricato... Lo sai che
questa è bona... Questa non è niente male. Questa te la magni, quella ti è sfuggito veramente. Ma senti poi...
Kechapposa... Molto kechapposa. È buona. Diciamo esperimento... Vogliamo dare i voti?
Questo è non classificato. Però vedi, guarda che bella che è da vedere. Ma diciamo infatti che è
buonissima? Tanto non la possono assaggiare...
No, no, non mentiamo... Aspetto sette e mezzo, sapore due... Due? Due! Vabbè cioè ho assaggiato
di peggio.Ragazzi questa è maionese, è tutto tranne che
maionese... Questo invece aspetto cinque... Cinque. Sapore... Sei e mezzo, sette meno? Sette meno! Le patate?
Le patate secondo me sono un sette più. Son venute bene. Sette più! Anche perché comunque c'erano
basse aspettative su queste patate.
Patate sette più. Questo è da dimenticare, io, io
io, io monterò il video senza la maionese. Censuri...